Palestinians in Jabba south of Janine in
the occupied West Bank they were
traveling in a car the witnesses say was
targeted by snipers on rooftops Israel
says the Palestinians were Fighters
carrying weapons and explosives earlier
I spoke to Anita Ibrahim who gave us an
update from the occupied West Bank
according to local Witnesses they say
that the Israeli forces have shot
heavily at a car engineering that at
least two people were in now according
to the Israeli army they say that they
were trying to arrest the men when they
engaged in an exchange of fire with the
Israeli forces now according to
witnesses there this did not happen
that's why people there are calling it
an assassination of these three men they
would imprisoned by the Israeli forces
and they were released just recently and
we've been hearing from Palestinians in
Janine that they will continue the fight
we were there yesterday with
Palestinians have buried six
Palestinians after they were killed in
an Israeli raid Palestinians say that
Israel only understands the language of
force that they will keep on the fight
and they will not be deterred by these
Israeli actions also in Janine a 14 year
old boy has succumbed to his wounds
after after he was wounded a few days
ago by Israeli forces he is a 14 year
old this raises the death toll just
since the beginning of this year to 78
Palestinians neither over the last
couple of weeks or so there have been
efforts to try to find some sort of way
of de-escalating this situation we saw
meetings that were happening in akaba in
Jordan for example is there any sign at
all that those efforts are actually
having any effect it's clear that Israel
is not stopping its rate to the occupied
West Bank just two days after those
understandings we had reached to meet in
Aqaba Israel raided nebulous and killed
10 Palestinians 11 actually Palestinians
in one raid so if you look at the
situation on the ground Palestinians
would tell you that the cause for their
resistance is the Israeli occupation
this is why they will continue the fight
but when it comes to Israel it says that
it will not allow those armed men men
that have been
increasing all across the occupied West
Bank to continue we see this phenomena
that has started in Janine but has moved
also to nablas and in other locations
we've seen Jericho had armed men being
involved in the fight so for Israel this
is a situation that they want to contain
they want to prevent Palestinians from
fighting but as far as Palestinians are
concerned they say that the leadership
can agree on whatever it wants to agree
on with Israel with the people want an
end to the occupation and they see the
armed struggle as one way of doing that
U.S defense secretary Lloyd Austin is
visiting Israel as protests continue
against the hard-ride government's
planned judicial overhaul Inland Khan is
joining us live now from West Jerusalem
this is part of a wider Regional tour
that Lloyd Ocean's been doing this visit
to Israel is during increased tension
will not just increased tension he's
actually arriving in a state that is in
a political crisis over the judicial
reform build that's being discussed
there's thousands of people out on the
streets across Israel 95 different
locations people are protesting they
were already going to be at the airport
where the meeting is going to take place
now
normally these meetings take place and
the defense Ministry Lloyd Austin and
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu aren't
actually going to go to the defense
Ministry Tel Aviv there's simply too
many protesters out in the streets Lloyd
Austin was supposed to arrive on
Wednesday night instead the Israelis
asked him to arrive Thursday morning to
the airport Benjamin Netanyahu is
actually being helicoptered to the
airport for that meeting to take place
it's extraordinary the circumstances
that this meeting is uh taking place
under now these protesters they are out
on the streets and they will try and get
their voice heard but what's likely to
be the scenario actually at the meeting
what's going to be discussed well
clearly Iran is going to be of concern
to both parties there's increasingly
hostile language that the Prime Minister
has been using about Iran for a number
of years now that's concerning some uh
in the US who are wondering if that
might lead to some sort of escalation
also maybe perhaps a distraction method
uh against the the protesters gives them
news media something else to talk about
so it's likely that that's being
discussed but remember Israel gets about
3.5 billion dollars a year in military
aid alone so having these meetings
between the Secretary of Defense and the
Israeli secretary defense of the Prime
Minister uh do take place on a fairly
regular basis but this uh is uh under a
very extraordinary circumstances given
the type of language and the makeup of
uh Benjamin netanyahu's own cabinet
which has caused alarm in U.S circles
particularly within the Biden
Administration it's Imran Khan talking
to us from West Jerusalem Imran thank
you